what please note this meeting will be
audio recorded should we be required to
evacuate the building with these things
leave the room by the doors the fire
escape staircase these hold both
handrails so quite know how because
nobody's that library video in case the
stairs are wet or slippery is probably
if anyone isn't able to use the stairs
but they please allow others to eat
syndrome whether it goes to the floor
escape door where they can be given
assistance moisture suppose our tent
before it will be the public toilet up
at the side of the c-suite
please do not delay the evacuation and
collecting belongings and please do not
return to the building until given
permission to do so by council staff so
good evening everyone welcome to another
example of a summer but there's hope it
comes back soon slab is on technological
textbook but apologies for absence I'll
be human apologies from cancer
scientists even counselor web I think
that's the ugly ones at the moment bill
bill is attending here to non-members
there could be cancer Williams and
counselor sure very welcome
thank you for coming along right minutes
to the meeting held on 1st of March is
it your wish I sign of his true record
we really thank you anything cannot in
those minutes not mentioned elsewhere we
have the gentleman who wants to grant
all okay any declarations of interest
please
just embrace right exam accounts attack
while I think it's a common interest
here if it can be noted but if anything
because you are in the course of the
meeting please declare it then and we'll
make sure it's recorded in the minutes
while item fired message refers to the
executive and reports from other
committees I'm not aware of any so the
first item is item 6 which is the
progress on decisions planning to go
through every tie each of this most of
its a lot is done actually by the rest
of it so as anybody wish to raise any
particular items please only quite not
right
so never accept the report this is
really item 7 get to the beginning of it
is the report where section 1.1 of the
sir we see it in very wording a
substitute thanks Maggie whisk and okay
I don't plan to go through to report on
my line but I'd like to do is just class
on a 15-point
first of all line 1.1 quite I like this
we've made and I would say this is a
provisional saving because all of our
accounts are subject to external audit
which is just beginning at the moment
and carry on through the summer
until we take final figured into Central
Committee but as it stands at the moment
we are looking to transfer 723 thousand
into earmarked reserves if we just turn
up the page to 7.2 as a table in
paragraph 2.3 which shows that 723
thousand now the underlying variants of
723 thousand but when you factor in
those projects that are being moved into
this one and really completely the
agilent their engineering 1.1 million
figures of folks on 723 thousand which
gives a really good achievement in
itself and go some way in helping the
authority with budget gap that we
continue to have just to kind of put
some emphasis on that if you look at
paragraph 2.1 and our revised final
budget for the year was 9 point 1
million and we came in at 8 million
pounds so again it's a good position to
be and hopefully something that we can
continue to carry on speaking for this
financial year 1718 as we as we move
through the year to some of the key
variances that make up that difference
an X or of commission gave us more money
than we were expecting
that's mainly through the receiver to
the technological operation if it who
the parousia pipe as you remember last
year we had we had to and exited the
district is impressions as well as only
corrected by so X
and from the Electoral Commission which
members in how to use our budget so it's
a second there please say carpark income
was up to 97 thousand powerful person
generated and budgeted always a bit of a
contentious item with the constraints
that we haven't what we can do with that
revenue cut they just say I'm better
than ever than we budgeted some of
marketing areas so we have 98 thousand
on recycling disposal which is basically
more material being recycled going
through generating those credit claims
than we budgeted plus it's life saving
on the material recycling facility which
is good the contract savings that
delivered on the street scene and
recycling contracts on the flip side as
as you're all aware and continues to be
homelessness is an issue for the
authority it's an issue for every
authority in country and will continue
to be an issue as we move through the
housing changes with the new housing and
community final where it's for seventeen
thousand four hundred pound adverse but
within that there were you turn
to pull it one point six paragraph one
point six one of the diseases that we're
recommending is is that the recovery
plan was put in place be agreed so that
seventeen thousand pound clearances are
for that recovery plan to this time the
online situation with costs and
temporary combination having said that
as we move into through this year we get
now getting closer to having people in
South Stream and promise Kakinada so
things and more into that as we go
forward and just this year's budget go
and that's revenue just thinking they're
slightly on capital and if you turn to
page seven point six which in appendix
two of the report title they're showing
our capital out turn for the year so the
original final object of the years just
over a million pounds now to just under
nine hundred thousand so we're carrying
fallen into this minor financial year
one hundred and forty two thousand
pounds worth of capital projects if you
like that we'd like to deliver in this
financial year
their recommendations that gets greens
just awesome I mean that's a lot
obviously yes if the next position is
absolutely yeah there are specific
projects that will be included in this
one a two-year that [ __ ] the Risen
plan work for one reason or not a
specific incentives maybe I don't have
anything else that I want to highlight
but I'm happy to take any questions
reshape their kids thank you
well done that and I got back to copper
revenue and I know
the jump orbitals are design differences
apart personal fulfillment commercial
can we make an earlier decision over
weekly analysis but we are going to have
three I think that's a good idea because
it needs to go out there so people who
claim you love me I think that's okay we
need to get that approach I did what has
mold around around information on this
this very issue
claims from
and that the obviously against posing
that I know a lot I'd like run over here
tonight here in there yeah all right
is it is only important for edit profile
such as it was all maybe within RIA the
portfolio balance the elastoplastic use
that congruent
can we please donate at least I think we
can't through the motion actually where
we are no please
it's a decision of the portfolio holder
so that that we today already
I think sure initially decided Institute
Jim nothing particular needs to be a
connotation for my client rotten apples
I am a bit but does make making sure
that
BF della Sera
market lion crisis and that's generally
perhaps just a local to one report which
is between brought before you in
September early September and where
you'll have an upside position on car
parking cub and then find then one quite
one we've had some influences
so then German come back I went in there
mix or councilman
so it's your left hand
Jesus
I obviously went to 17th October yeah
sometimes I guess so that's double time
time to us yes
yes so they do I appreciate Matthew
severely returns Romania and car passing
and this is historically better if you
say a gray area is there any further
clarification on this gray area
my understanding an element of no expert
on it but my understanding is as long as
we can prove that we're putting revenue
back into transportation services so
what street parking on street parking
any highways that we adopt every mile
and then should find really really
different view we're not all the streets
parking is very clear yet income on
street not in this competitive industry
so I can be equipped must be invested
back into highway infrastructure that
would serve on street parking
I think there's not apply to Occupy Wall
Street apartment including separate
grant animal as you think of the private
sector car park to do they which only
reaches that point
Metapod it's a very is imperative you
have didn't differing view but saving
the - agents of bridging part of the
association that packs with unit time
push forward
that they were very entities distinctive
think on on-screen or three albums that
memphis we think that on street parking
haven't reviewed that you always being
taxed twice if you're not careful page
of our attacks on the infrastructure in
why do you hide from street parking
you're almost paying so it's a privilege
apartment something we paid to have
surface intuition so telling the idea
that that must be reinvested but off
street car park our facility tuned for
cover the very investing in developing
could be you
supporting processes
- matter for members deciding how I wish
budget we spent anyway but I think we've
been talking to the does you know the
agenda here so I think that's something
that could be raised in the greater yes
Roger yeah any other questions please
so we've got several items there have
been recommended so that's from one
point one through the 1.9 he knows
essentially authenticate on that very
transaction 7i tonight is reportedly
integrate service route horrible
Authority balls and I think nominations
oh yes pride so that would be your self
like yes ma'am okay so hopefully you're
a reasonable Sailor morosely
other than that our characters on I've
sunk it's very uh not fun
well that's reassuring very very
reasonable beings ranges it hasn't okay
it didn't want to speak to this tool
members of Korea that okay thanks a
consummate item nine is the exclusive
resolution rather than reading them is
all you're happy to accept it if you
enjoy